look at you looking just 100
I'm here
okay talk to me about this look what's
one secret we would want to know about
your fashion the designer of this dress
is from Houston Texas and I'm excited
his name is Bach
so he got me snatched tonight I'm happy
come on Bob okay speaking of Houston you
get your Renaissance tickets or what oh
I'm gonna tell you why I got him four
okay but you don't be hating on me but I
got them okay I know you have a direct
line oh baby you know I called up them
directly I think hey
yeah let me tell you let me ask you are
you going to their party tonight I know
they have a little while after this I am
oh man Beyonce is my auntie I know that
but you said I have to stop by Vanity
Fair first for uh what a quick one two
this is my first night out and I'm here
I'm ready hey real quick are you working
any new music can we expect a new song
new album
[Music]